je viens pas faire la police je viens
juste dire à une personne qui ont été
victimes que si jamais elles ont besoin
de quelqu'un qui les soutiennent et qui
a qui a été témoin parce qu'en fait je
les ai vus si l'avant entre mes mains
cette vidéo je serai pas là en fait ça
on serait devant les tribunaux je pense
vous avez essayé d'alerter quelqu'un oui
j'ai alerté plusieurs productions donc
toutes les productions des princes de
l'amour toutes les productions avec
l'egypte à ce moment là jugé averti des
personnes très haut placées dans toutes
les productions qu'est ce que vous a dit
j'ai une des productions qui m'a répondu
que
[Musique]
ouais c'est là que c'est très grave en
fait c'est que
c'est un milieu de la chance fait tous
des lâches clairement et les productions
protègent certaines choses alors je sais
pas pourquoi
moi quand j'ai expliqué à une personne
très haut placées d'une production ce
que je venais de voir quelques semaines
avant parce que je me suis retrouvé à un
endroit où je savais que ça allait être
compliqué et je les fais en interne
parce que j'ai pas la vidéo je peux pas
aller porter plainte on m'a dit alors je
suis pas au courant de cette vidéo par
contre je sais qu'il ya eu des problèmes
avec d'autres personnes d'ailleurs on a
une personne qu'il souhaite pas venir à
cause d'eux ensuite on m'a dit
d'ailleurs les nounous ont été avertis
que ça peut être dangereux donc ils ont
une information qui fait qu' il faut
qu'ils soient un petit peu plus présents
elie gilles ans pour pas que cette
personne se retrouve seul avec des
jeunes filles
moi j'entends ça ça veut dire que je
vais bien la présomption d'innocence et
que la personne soupçonnée sera dans les
princes et les princesses deux amoureux
partir de la semaine prochaine ce qui
l'attend mais moi je n'ai jamais dit ça
ça c'est ce que vous avez donc c'est lui
même qui a dit que c'était lui les
réguliers qui était aussi sa de ce jeune
homme a envie de se dénoncer
et de dire qu'on parle de lui che le
fasse c'est moi et ses mauvais coups moi
je ne dénonce personnes jeunes et nominé
personne parce que la seule personne les
seules personnes à qui je nommerai les
personnes de cette situation ce sera
face aux institutions qui peuvent faire
quelque chose aujourd'hui je peux
difficilement le faire parce que je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
étouffés d'ailleurs je suis pas la seule
à pouvoir vous dire genre de choses je
pense et c'est surtout que je veux que
si jamais ses victimes elle elles
comprennent il ya personne qu'il ya au
dessus des lois et on est là aussi et
moi je veux qu'elle comprenne ça donc
c'est pour ça que je suis là aujourd'hui
c'est pas pour accuser qui que ce soit
c'est juste pour dire que s'il ya des
victimes faut pas qu'elles qu'elles
restent dans le silence et qu'elle se
sente faut qu'elle se sente accompagner
parce que on s'était plus nature a
dit que benjamin on a vu votre fils il
m'en parlait même de cette vidéo y est
ce que vous étiez au courant c'est un
fait il m'en a parlé il était il était
absolument choquée pour le coup il l'a
vu la vidéo alors non je crois qu'il n'a
pas vus ils ont entendu parler et je
sais un peu pour savoir qui c'est un peu
un peu révolté un peu rebellé contre la
personne quand on a parlé il était très
en colère mais ça l'a surtout le
traumatisés parce qu'effectivement si
tout ça était est avéré tout si tout ça
est vrai il ya plusieurs problèmes et ça
à différents niveaux au niveau
évidemment des candidats qui nous quitte
au courant qu'ils n'ont pas parlé la
production je mettrais un bémol parce
que l'équipement est ce que l'effet est
ce qu'on était totalement au courant ou
pas je suis désolé a besoin de tes rempl
mais on ne prend pas le risque d'aller
dénoncer ce genre d'agissements jeudi
parce qu'il n'ya rien je dis pas que
c'est faux que du rire moi je pense que
l'histoire je souffre puisque simon en a
parlé mais après je pense qu'il faut
c'est de traiter ça globale non mais
c'est vrai que pour le coup de la part
de simon qui a fait c est mis sur les
qui a fait notamment les marseillais
contre le reste du monde où il était au
courant où ils étaient en colère et où
il était choqué et outré ça je confirme
totalement les propos d'alex